d'où venaient tullins de belfast
tu allais vous à dublin pour contrainte
c'est la frontière il ya un an l'irlande
du nord qui est rattachée à l'angleterre
est en bas l'irlande du sud qui est une
république indépendante
voilà une frontière qui pourrait
réapparaître avec le bric site
les pays de l'union européenne doivent
se réunir et définir les grandes lignes
des futures négociations avec londres
les obstacles seront nombreux complexes
et parmi eux la question de la frontière
entre la république d'irlande et le
royaume uni les nationalistes irlandais
obtiennent l'indépendance en 1921 la
république d'irlande profondément
catholique vient de naître mais amputée
de ses terres septentrionale dans cette
irlande du nord sous domination anglaise
les protestants sont majoritaires mais
les irlandais catholiques du nord ou du
sud n'accepte pas cette séparation très
chaleureux dans l'âme la frontière
n'existe pas n'a jamais existé c'est
seulement une politique alors que les
protestants du nord eux ne veulent pas
quitter la couronne britannique pendant
des décennies sa frontière a été un
point de cristallisation lira groupes
paramilitaires qui luttaient pour
l'unification de lille
utilisez l'irlande du sud comme base
arrière pour préparer ses attentats en
irlande du nord
l'armée a décidé depuis quelques jours
d'employer la manière forte pour
s'opposer à cet ennemi invisible qui
s'appelle lire à l barrent les routes et
fait sauter des âmes
des kilomètres de frontière en réalité
impossible à contrôler il est en effet
très difficile de bloquer efficacement
cette frontière serpente invisible
capricieuse à travers champs dans la
seule région de rosslyn 42 route ont été
recensés par l'armée trois seulement
ouverte et contrôlé huit fermé par des
blocs de béton
toutes les autres interdite à la
circulation quant aux postes frontières
ils se font régulièrement plastique et
une situation dramatique parfois
grotesques comme c'est rappeler ici en
le douanier sur l'irlandais est obligé
de travailler dans une caravane
alors personne n'a admis la
responsabilité mais on pense dans la
région que c'était les foi de ce temps
évidemment au filet catane et comptait
fonder l'autre lire art on va voir tout
à l'heure et l'irs a fait sauter l'eau
peut alors faire danser quand c'était
les protestants lui vf qui ont fait
sauter ce défi ce conflit meurtrier
prend fin avec l'accord du vendredi
saint en avril 98 la frontière est
désormais ouverte pour les irlandais du
nord et du sud
alors le départ des britanniques de
l'union européenne va t'il réveiller les
vieux démons pour les irlandais en tout
cas pas question de voir ressurgir les
barbelés
[Musique]